oh it looks so gross what if we do hi
I'm kelcie so a lot of my friends would
probably consider me an indoors person I
do like a challenge and I love adventure
however my biggest hobbies would
probably be gaming watching television
sitting with my dog on a couch so it
would come as a surprise to most people
that I thought it would be a really fun
idea to try to survive the Australian
outback a lot of my friends thought
otherwise
hey Caitlyn you're from the outback
right what do you think about me going
so basically I'm gonna fly to Broken
Hill Australia in the middle of the
outback I'll have just the things on me
I'll have a little bit of Flint a water
bottle protein bar just for safety
purposes I don't pass out so first we're
going to be meeting with the landowner
we're actually going to be shooting on
private property his place is gonna be
the only civilization for miles my
name's Colin Claire your limestone
station do you wish to Broken Hill about
15,000 acres heat mid-30s could range to
38 40 first to fill much water no water
no life hydration is important depending
on the duration food's important as well
but I've got to tell you there's not
much out there of either
there'll be bugs out there whether
you'll be quick enough to catch him is
another story we do have some native
berries and stuff out there but finding
it it's few and far between you're gonna
struggle with a little burn so if you've
got some we're getting into light then
there's plenty of small verbage as long
as you go in hydrated the reality is I
guess you can get to the other end
without finding water in 24 hours but
food you're gonna struggle don't try
this at home this is for real we arrived
at the station I was blindfolded put
into a car and they drove me out into
the outback I don't think it really hit
me yet so far it's kind of fun I'm not
gonna lie like I'm excited they dropped
us off with all of our stuff we wave
goodbye to the car
I was pretty anxious what if we do my
first task was to kind of gather some
stuff up start making camp for the night
maybe you're just a secret lara croft
and we don't know about it yet that's
like the end goal here is i just want to
be a female bear girls look at that
there's more oh look a literal thing
died out here that next thing could be
me so we've been here for like 45
minutes I think and Kelsey's already
started talking to us look at this
pretty thing though look at that I'm
gonna keep it it's gonna be my friend I
don't know if that's just something that
helps her get through this situation
would be like my Wilson this looks like
something I could use I felt like I was
doing really well and that the Sun
started setting I kind of hit me like oh
my gosh I need to seriously start
getting this fire going I saw one spark
hi have you ever set your fire before no
I was sitting there creating sparks for
ever but luckily after a long a long
time we finally got something to light
it could still die everyone's gonna die
eventually I felt like the thing I did
best was make a fire there was nothing
like that feeling
you've got marshmallows just kidding we
only have bugs I've been laying here for
a little while
it's beautiful but I don't know if I'm
really gonna get any sleep tonight
I do feel hungry I do feel tired I do
feel a little dehydrated but it's
nothing bad yet
good morning and I just think I found a
bug that is quite large tea this morning
so breakfast is here he's not he's for
sure dead oh it looks so gross Oh No
there was like goo inside it's 8:45
right now we're packing up camp ready to
head out so we only have 8 hours and 15
minutes I think left from now until then
we're gonna be trying to find water
trying to find maybe more crickets so we
started walking and it was a lot there's
quite literally nothing like I I can see
absolutely zero civilization from where
I'm standing and I can see pretty far I
haven't found any water I've hardly
found any bugs we just lucked out on
finding fruits it kind of hit me how
desolate how terrifying this could be so
we finally found an area that looks like
some kind of body of water I'm gonna see
if I can find the deepest end maybe the
digging is much harder than I
anticipated I've been digging for 15 to
20 minutes now I still have found water
I'm kind of getting tired I know that
I'm supposed to dig deeper but I just
don't have the tools I don't want to
call it yet though I'm gonna keep trying
for like a little bit longer I think is
what he was talking about about like a
bigger creek bed already dig a hole I'm
thinking Garou to be honest
[Music]
kind of found a little road so I'm gonna
follow that because it's very likely
that in any kind of survival situation
if you did find a road going along that
probably will lead to something however
you'll have to make sure you know what
direction you're going in because you
could be just going further into the
outback but I have figured out the
direction I think we're on the right
path I feel a little light-headed but
nothing she is a really really bubbly
person I would love to eat a hot dog I'd
love to I would we have three and a half
hours to go feel like we need to start
figuring out where civilization is I
think we're getting close though we're
gonna have some traffic up ahead
oh my god there's just so many a little
bit yeah yeah I survived the UH pack for
24 hours
we did it we found water we found food
made a fire I did all the things I think
the outdoors and survival in general are
things that I always loved watching the
right precautions in order and like with
training and stuff it's a lot of fun so
I highly recommend going out camping and
staying safe in the wilderness